that's right speech accents that is the
dependent coastal ISM with associated
with this idea for stability you know
you can take it anywhere it's a religion
that is portable and all silence it
should be accessible you said
availability in spiritual gifts yeah
right what's the regional so when you're
speaking with it these are two aspects
of Pentecostalism that I don't
associating with fundamentalist Islam I
usually don't associate those two
qualities no can you explain why
fundamentalist Islam as thus on the rise
doesn't have these these actually well
I'm carefully I'm always careful to
avoid expressing a expertise about Islam
at all because I always find that what
I've just gained from the expert a is is
contradicted by us but B so I just have
to kind of take an amalgam from the
various expertise that are offered me
about Islam but with that little sort of
defensive people it it it seems to me
that the Islam is fundamentally integral
I mean the Catholic term was for this in
Europe was antia and anti-b stir or in
the latin american term was antichrist
and that is that there is some
relationship between the the integrity
all the Integrity's of one's belonging
are connected and that is what they
relate to territory they relate to
political power they they relate to the
relationship with religion and a
particular territory so that a certain
territory is defined as inherently
belong to a a particular faith and and
the catholicism also to some extent has
done done that him in a jesuit said to
me what right if they got to go to Latin
America I mean that what right you know
it said that the notion of pluralism is
not universally accepted the same stew
of Eastern Orthodox charities has this
sense of its own canonical territory
if this is not a straight forwardly
Islam and Islamic Christian difference
it is the difference between those
religions who who have this sense of of
a fundamental inherent connection
between a faith and the territory and
those that have built on the pluralistic
Fissel possibilities that lie within the
Christian repertoire but obviously the
relationship between a faith and a
territory and and the integrity of a
culture is a very powerful influence now
to the extent that Islam feels itself
threatened by those kinds of
modernization that are related to
westernization which isn't the same
thing as technology that's likely to act
as a mobilizing force and and a
reinforcing element let me just add one
tiny further thing and that is that
technology itself is not modernization
in terms of technology is not a factor
that leads to secularization it's clear
that you can use the most modern
technology and be a society that's
deeply religious grant Wagner who talks
about Pentecostalism says it is
searching for Eden with a satellite dish
so technology and religion are not
necessarily opposed